let me put it like this if I wasn't a
writer if I was just a director out
there getting a script I would probably
have to engage in subtextual film
criticism in order to make the piece of
my own I don't try to engage in it
whatsoever when it comes to my work I
learned how I didn't want to do that at
the Sundance Institute because I was
there with Reservoir Dog part of the
thing I was invited to the director's
workshop and one of the director goes
have you done your subtext work you've
done the writer work you haven't done
the director work you need to do your
subtext work oh he's describing this
whole thing to me and I was like wow is
that really what a director does all of
a sudden the more I wrote the more I
realized the movie was the father-son
story and me as a student at Sundance is
in my little Bungalow and I was like I'm
glad to know my work has such depth I'm
glad to know that the roots extend that
far deep but I never want to know about
those roots again because I know they're
there and I don't want to tell a
father-son story I want to tell my
gangster story the father-son story will
take care of itself and the father-son
story is there because it is deeper than
just a robbery but me I want to deal
with robbery